society is so tense and waiting for
failure robots you're in a such a high
stake environment failure has such a
high cost and it slows down development
it slows down development yeah like the
team like definitely noticed that like
once you go driverless like where
driveways from phoenix and you continue
to iterate
your iteration pace slows down
because your fear
of regression
forces
so much more rigor that you know
obviously
you know you have to find a compromise
on like okay well how often do we
release driverless builds because every
time you release a driver's build you
have to go through this like validation
process which is very expensive so far
so um it is interesting it's like it is
one of the hardest things there's no
other industry where like uh you would
not like you wouldn't release the
products way way quicker when you start
to kind of provide
even portions of the value that you
provide healthcare maybe is the other
one
that's right but at the same time right
like we've gotten there where you think
of like surgery right like you have
surgery there's always a risk but like
it's really really bounded you know that
there's an accident rate when you go out
and drive your car today right like uh
and you know what the fatality rate in
the u.s is per year we're not banning
driving because there was a car accident
but the bar for us is way higher and we
hold ourselves very serious to it where
you have to not only be better than a
human but you probably have to like at
scale be far better than a human by a
big margin and you have to be able to
like really really thoughtfully explain
um all of the ways that we validate that
becomes very comfortable for humans to
understand because a bunch of jargon
that we use internally just doesn't
compute at the end of the day we have to
be able to explain to society how do we
quantify the risk
and acknowledge that there is some
non-zero risk but it's far above a human
you know relative safety see here's the
thing
to push back a little bit
uh and bring cosmo back into
conversation he said something quite
brilliant at the beginning of this
conversation i think probably applies
for
autonomous driving which is
you know there's this desire to make
autonomous cars much safer than human
driven cars
but
if you create a product that's really
compelling and is able to explain both
the leadership and the engineers and the
product itself
can communicate intent
then i think people may be able to be
willing to put up with the thing that
might be even riskier than humans
because
they understand the value of taking
risks you mentioned the speed limit
humans understand the value of going
over the speed limit yeah humans
understand the value of like
going fast through a for through a
yellow light yeah to take in when you're
in manhattan streets pushing through uh
uh crossing pedestrians they understand
that i mean this is a much more tense
topic of discussion so this is just me
talking so in with cosmo's case there
was something about the way
this particular robot communicated the
energy brought the intent it was able to
communicate to to the humans that you
understood
that of course it needs to have a camera
yeah of course he needs to have this
information and in that same way to me
of course a car needs to take risks of
course there's going to be accidents
that's what
like that's
you know if you want a car that never
has an accident
have a car that just doesn't go anywhere
yeah and so that
but that's tricky because that's not a
robotics problem
any accidents like are not even under
like due to you right obviously
so there's a big difference though um
yeah you are
that's not a personal decision you're
also impacting obviously kind of the
rest of the road um and we're
facilitating it right and so there's a
higher kind of you know kind of ethical
immoral bar which obviously then you
know translates into as a society and
from a regulatory standpoint kind of
like what comes out of it where
it's hard for us to ever see this even
being uh
debate in the sense that like you have
to be beyond reproach from a safety
standpoint because if you're wrong about
this you could set the entire field back
a decade right see i i this is me
speaking i think if we look into the
future
there will be
i personally believe
this is me speaking yeah
that there will be less and less focus
on safety they're still very very high
yeah meaning like after autonomy is very
common and accepted it's not not not so
common as everywhere but there has to be
a transition because
i think for innovation just like you
were saying
to explore ideas you have to take risks
and i think
if autonomy
in the near term is to become prevalent
in society i think people need to be
more willing to understand the nature of
risk
the value of risk
it's very difficult you're right of
course with driving
but that's the fascinating nature of it
this it's a it's a life and death
situation that brings value to millions
of people so you have to figure out what
what do we value about this world how
much do we value
how deeply do we want to avoid
hurting other humans that's right and
there is a point where like
you can imagine a scenario where waymo
has a system
that is uh even when it's like uh kind
of beyond a you know human relative
safety um and
provably statistically
will save lives
there is a
thoughtful navigation of
you know the that fact versus just you
kind of society readiness and perception
and
education of um
[Music]
society and regulators and everything
else where like
it's it's multi-dimensional um and it's
not a purely logical
argument but um
ironically the logic can actually help
with the emotions
and just like any technology there's
early adopters and then there's kind of
like a curve that um happens after it
but eventually celebrities you get the
rock in a way more vehicle and then
everybody just comes in and then
everybody calms down because the rock
likes it yeah
if you post uh yeah and it's like it's
an open question on how this plays out i
mean maybe we're pleasantly surprised
and it just like people just realize
that this is such a enabler of life and
like efficiency and cost and everything
that um there's a pull like at some
point i should fully believe that this
will go from a
thoughtful kind of you know
you know movement and tiptoeing and like
kind of like a push to society realizes
how wonderful of an enabler this could
become and it becomes more of a pull and
um hard to know exactly how that will
play out but at the end of the day like
both the goods transportation and the
people transportation side of it has
that property where
it's not easy there's a lot of open
questions and challenges to navigate and
there's obviously the technical problems
to solve uh as a you know kind of
prerequisite but um
they they have such an opportunity that
is um
on a scale that very few industries in
the last 20 30 years have even had a
chance to tackle that
i
maybe were pleasantly surprised by how
much how much that tipping point like in
a very short amount of time actually
turns into a societal pull to kind of
embrace the benefits of this yeah i i
hope so it seems like in the recent few
decades there's been tipping points to
technologies where like overnight things
change it's uh like uh from taxis to
ride sharing services all that that
shift i mean there's just shift after
shift after shift that requires
digitization and technology i'm i hope
we're pleasantly surprised in this
you